sind sie auch so wahnsinnig erleichtert
unsere groko ist doch nicht geplatzt
jedenfalls noch nicht zur erinnerung die
älteren werden sich erinnern
hans-georg maßen der chef des
verfassungsschutzes sollte für seinen
skandal interview mit der bild die
gerechte strafe erhalten eine fristlose
beförderung ja also ich muss dazu sagen
das ist jetzt mein stand kurz nach 18
uhr wenn wir die sendung hier
aufzeichnen es kann gut sein dass die
groko im laufe dieses abends noch
mehrmals ihre meinung ändert sie ja sie
zuhause wissen jetzt mehr als ich ne
vielleicht hat merkel den mars
inzwischen rausgeschmissen und eröffnen
mit horst seehofer eine herrenboutique
in wuppertal ich habe keine ahnung ich
weiß es nicht es ist
19.30 uhr die kanzlerin das land ist ja
auch egal ich sage mal ganz ehrlich kein
mensch versteht mehr diese krukow
hans-georg maßen bisher chef des
verfassungsschutzes wird befördert
ein echter karrieresprung hans-georg
börsen herzlichen glückwunsch mehr geld
gibt es auch mehr als vorher 3000 euro
mehr im monat was ist dein
entscheidungen die er sehe vor erklären
muss was für ein schmierentheater
wirklich was für ein schmierentheater da
wären wirklich sämtliche klischees über
die berliner politik bestätigt der fall
maßen ist für mich so was wie die
perfekte bauanleitung für noch mehr
politikverdrossenheit wie soll man das
der bevölkerung erklären
jetzt verdienen da ja noch mehr und wer
ist schuld
seehofer die frage war doch zu einfach
wenn er denn befördert wird wie gesagt
um diese uhrzeit wir sind es nicht und
unabhängig vom fall maßen geht das elend
ja weiter in der gruppe merkel und
seehofer haben doch nur noch ein ziel
sich gegenseitig den lebensabend
versauen sonst nichts mehr wirklich
ja sie hat inzwischen 0 autorität und
der horst dreht ja völlig frei der
drehte man kann ja merkel und ihre
politik furchtbar finden von mir aus
aber noch nicht während man gleichzeitig
seinen alten minister hintern in ihrem
kabinett park das geht nicht
was denn los mit dem man natürlich hoffe
ich auch mit ihren maßen gesprochen wird
sie gestern jedenfalls nicht nur
wochenende und lass stecken haus so
wichtig ist es auch nicht
die meisten leute interessiert schon gar
nicht mehr so und was noch trauriger ist
was bitte ist mit der guten alten spd
los was ist los bei den sozen die nahles
hat doch der beförderung von maßen
ausdrücklich zugestimmt und heute tritt
sich vor die presse und sagt guten abend
lag drei parteivorsitzenden haben am
dienstag zusammen gesessen und eine
entscheidung getroffen die auf breites
unverständnis in der bevölkerung
gestoßen ist und wir haben nicht
vertrauen geschaffen sondern wir haben
vertrauen verloren
wir haben uns alle drei geirrt doch auch
sein mag ich meine wer konnte denn auch
ahnen dass die leute das nicht mögen
wenn man für scheiße bauen belohnt
würden
vielleicht einfach mal vorher nachdenken
das wäre für die glaubwürdigkeit
wichtiger als sagen wir mal modefragen
wir haben uns gestern abend was sie
heute einziehen der meinung gut und wir
sind heute alle drei geburt und wieder
fünf prozent verloren kommt euch kann
man nicht mehr helfen spd wirklich wenn
hans georg maßen tatsächlich
staatssekretärin seehofers
innenministerium wird und sie gesagt ich
weiß es nicht um diese uhrzeit dann muss
da natürlich einer gehen schwierig wen
schmeißt man daraus warte mal was hat
der denn da ein spd parteibuch
dann nehmen wir den doch hier unter
adler problem sehen sie selbst sind
immer noch alles männer aber auch dafür
hatte horst eine lösung eine kleine
dicke rechts muss sich operieren lassen
[Musik]